hey guys just a quick bumper before we
start this video over on the discord
server and you'll find a link down in
the description but over on the discord
server we are looking for more
moderators our discord server has grown
to about 6 200 people
it's nuts we need more moderators for
the discord so if you are interested
head over to the discord server and look
for the moderator application channel
and you'll see the kind of questions
that we're asking uh if you need some
help with that
just below that channel is the moderator
application help
channel and that'll basically walk you
through the process and tell you why
we're asking the kind of questions that
we're asking and what it is that we're
looking for in moderators so make sure
you guys go check that out
and uh yeah let's begin
alright what's going on guys this is rob
and we are picking up with the aftermath
2 joker war and this kind of start of a
whole new batman and this is cool
if i'm being honest with you guys i love
this this new direction
that dc's taking batman in and if i'm
being honest
i kind of feel like it's a long time
coming to be honest with you guys and
and you guys will see what i mean by the
time we get to the end of this but
initially this this kind of picks up
with a bit of musing on behalf of bruce
wayne right in the aftermath of
everything that's going on it's a little
bit amusing here and he talks about how
the way things used to be right back in
the day and when i say back in the day i
mean
for quite some time in dc comics really
since like the introduction of batman in
the very early days in the sense that
when we had commissioner gordon when we
had the introduction of the bat signal
when you had alfred that thing's kind of
followed this pattern
that bruce wayne would begin his night
you know as batman you put on this
cloaking cowl he'd go out into the city
and then like the bat signal might come
up right and that was just kind of an
indicator of hey things are popping off
come and see me uh commissioner gordon
would say that you know come and see me
and i'll kind of give you the skinny on
what's happening throughout gotham as a
whole now once bruce wayne was given
this rundown it'd be left to him to
decide
which one needed the most attention
basically right and once he narrowed
that down he kind of investigate the
various clues somehow sometimes he would
do this with robin other times he would
do it by himself he'd have alfred in his
ear kind of giving him some advice and
and you know as an outside perspective
uh he'd get back to the bat cave alfred
would basically
push him to eat or drink something but
batman would always have this idea of if
i stay here and investigate long enough
i can kind of put the clues together and
i can solve this case
and that was the form and function by
which everything in gotham city worked
and then seemingly
over the course of a single night or
over the course of an exceedingly short
period of time
all that went away alfred died
commissioner gordon's out of the picture
the joker who managed to successfully
take over gotham city batman's lost
pretty much all of his resources right
it's kind of just him
and a lot of this this discussion that
he has really you know really comes from
selena kyle and that's when she's kind
of like i can see that look on your face
it dries it drives me insane i hate it
it's that you've made a decision
and it's gonna change both of our lives
and it's the right decision to make but
you know that it's going to suck in
terms of this decision and my initial
thought was
batman's calling it off right he's
basically telling celina like we're no
longer together anymore
the reality of this is he basically kind
of says joker was right
i've been doing this i've been doing
this all wrong for a very long time
and that's true right batman's been
doing this wrong for a very very lengthy
amount of time right and the way this
the reason why this kind of comes out
picks up about a week ago and we
basically end up picking up with grifter
now the reality is that grifter's a
character i don't really know a whole
lot about i know enough to know that he
comes from the wildstorm imprint which
was created by
by jim lee and brandon troy back in the
day back in the 90s and he was part of a
group called international operations i
think it was kind of like an espionage
spy team wild storm was largely its own
universe it was just kind of out there
doing its own thing
in the aftermath of flashpoint and the
launch of the new 52 wild storm became
part of the main dc line of comics but
that's really all i know about grifter
and honestly i don't really care that
much to know anything more about him
he's not interesting to me i don't
really care much about his character for
the longer shorter for the sake of this
video since
you know this channel really is designed
to educate you guys the nature of
grifter is such that he
he has powers in so far as as
telekinetic abilities he's exceedingly
fast he's a great con
artist right he was a he was a member of
the us military
special ops team or group or whatever
you want to call it before he deserted
and became a con man effectively
he was at one point involved with a
group of aliens called
daemonites or demonized i'm not 100 sure
how to pronounce that they basically
tried to
possess him to take over his physical
form uh he ended up escaping and then
for the most part he's just kind of been
somewhat of a wanderer i think and
really more just kind of like a hired
gun like a mercenary uh but in this
particular instance here he's basically
working as a bodyguard for lucius fox
right now batman's aware of who grifter
is the fight between them is really
interesting and if anything
i think it's really one of these
attempts by dc to say hey guys like look
at this guy grifter you know he's pretty
interesting um i don't think anybody's
really buying it
but he's he's capable enough to where he
can kind of fight batman to a stand
still but he's basically been hired as a
bodyguard by lucious fox and the reason
for this is as part of the holdover with
regards to joker war
lucius fox is still the person in
possession of batman's wealth right of
bruce wayne's wealth and really kind of
the guy running wayne enterprises now in
in the videos that we do where we do
like a character explanation or team
explanation or something like that we'll
talk about stories that happen over the
course of a character's publication
history
that basically changes things up that
kind of initiates a huge status quo
that's what this is right this is a
massive status quo change for batman and
so you guys are literally reading
history in real time in this particular
instance right for those of you guys who
bought the book who are reading it right
now you're reading through history like
a huge history change in real time how
long it lasts we don't really know but
the idea behind this is that with
lucious fox more or less kind of running
the show here effectively being a
billionaire there's a few things going
on
the first is that he still harbors some
ill will towards batman in the sense
that everything that happened with joker
war you know the way that he was
infected by joker toxin and all that
kind of stuff the experiences left him
largely with some measure of ptsd now
the other part of that is we kind of get
this indication that punchline is still
around but she's kind of out there
talking to the press and things like
that that
was dc teasing us with an idea of
punchlines mini-series or maybe her
ongoing series i'm not really sure but
the other part of that is you still have
clown hunter and clown hunter is still
basically going through tracking down
members who are part of joker's gang and
then taking them out where he finds them
now the reason why this matters is
because
in the aftermath of joker war in the
fall of the joker those individuals who
were part of his army
vanished because their leader was
effectively gone and their their chance
of success right their chance of of kind
of having the world as they wanted it to
be
actually coming to fruition was gone
right so it was basically you guys lost
and in that instance you know in that
case they basically took off and they
they backed down right
they ended up basically kind of going
underground and that's an important
distinction to understand here
there's a difference between quitting
and just going to a place where you
can't be detected
and that's basically what was happening
here for the the joker's army in terms
of putting on the masks and going on
going out every night and doing things
that's over right they don't really do
that anymore instead they meet
underground they meet in places that are
not easily found and then plot or plan
accordingly now the joker's still out
there and as far as we're aware the
joker doesn't really have any
involvement with his own gang because as
we know is the reader the joker doesn't
really care about those guys
they believe the joker cares and they
they hope the joker cares but the joker
doesn't really care about them they were
cannon fodder right they were a means to
achieve an end now whether or not they
were intelligent enough to realize that
is a wholly different beast and in times
of desperation
people believe what they want to believe
and what ended up happening here is you
had people who wanted things to be a
certain way
the joker represented that way and
ultimately they kind of
tied the two together of their own
volition the joker's saying things i
like and and the joker is espousing
ideologies i agree with therefore the
joker agrees with me the joker
likes me and and the results of that is
they ended up kind of becoming the
people that they were becoming now the
joker basically kind of falling
joker having been defeated or at the
very least a scheme ending kind of puts
him in a position to whereas well the
joker's still out there the joker will
save us
you know i'm kind of making some
assumptions here but you know it's it's
it's interesting it basically means that
joker's army is not wholly dead
albeit very much you know much smaller
than it used to be but the long and
short of this
is that there are some major things
going on with bruce wayne and especially
wayne man
wayne wayne enterprises and lucious fox
that lucious fox to a degree kind of
enjoys the idea of having all this
wealth you know he goes as far as to say
i'm not going to lie i
lie to you and say that like it's fine
you know that the
you know i don't want this money doesn't
benefit me it does it benefits me it
benefits my family
that's the truth of the matter right
having these funds at my disposal but
understand
that wayne enterprises is looking to
force you out right like you are a
member of the board but they're looking
to basically give you like a huge chunk
of change let you just kind of draw
income
seemingly for the rest of your life and
then you go away now you basically end
up stepping down from when enterprises
is part of the board you have no
decision-making ability anymore more so
than that the reason why
is because the heat's on to you right
the government is looking at you one of
the big things that came out of joker
war was how
how bruce wayne was spending his money
offshore accounts different things like
that and so the irs and the financial
sector of the federal government right
so seemingly the secret service if
there's any indication of fraud on a
massive level being invoked they're
looking into bruce wayne and so the more
he's in the public eye
the more heat and scrutiny he draws onto
wayne enterprises and so it's best for
business that bruce wayne stepped down
and that's one of the big reasons why
lucious fox is kind of holding on to
this money
the other part of that is that the
notion that the public perception out
there that bruce wayne is a person who
was potentially engaging in embezzlement
or at the very least tax fraud right
like you know or
even just dodging taxes is not good for
the public for public perception of
wayne enterprises and so one of the
other reasons why they wanted to step
down is so they can rebrand right they
can rebrand wayne enterprises right all
new all different wayne enterprises or
something like that hopefully not as bad
as what marvel did
you know in the aftermath of secret wars
but the whole point behind that is
they're looking to literally
distance themselves from bruce wayne and
so the important thing behind this and
the reason why this matters is that
bruce wayne
cannot operate as batman the way he's
done in the past but just to say with a
unlimited checkbook and all the
high-tech gadgetry in the world that at
the end
batman's gonna have to operate on the
most basic level there's no high-tech
gadgetry there's no super advanced
batmobiles with all the resources in the
world that just come
off of some endless supply chain it
doesn't work that way anymore that he's
got a batmobile if the batmobile breaks
down he's got to fix it now there's a
couple reasons for why this is happening
the first
is because at this point it's obvious
dc's bringing batman comics
more in line with robert pattinson's
batman film the other part of this is
because we've seen this happen before
the most notable instance came in 1969
during the frank robbins and edmund
hamilton era with batman number 217
and this was a point where dick grayson
had basically left to go to college and
the result of this is
that bruce wayne actually ended up
leaving wayne manor and taking up
residence in the city of gotham and the
reason why that's important is because
what you end up having here
is this conversation between himself and
selena kyle where he says
that's what i want to do now one of the
one of the little moments that comes out
of this this is really more of a plot
point that'll become important later on
is that when bruce wayne ends up leaving
uh leaving lucious fox right leaving
that office he tells grifter like send a
message to your boss
right and tell like send a message to
lucious fox tell him i know what halo is
and basically i'm watching it looks like
it's you know some kind of
little bit of an underground thing some
kind of plot point that we'll see later
on down the line but kind of picking
back up with bruce wayne and selena kyle
again he basically says
i'm gonna move into the city itself and
that's what he did in the aftermath
really with batman 217 he ended up
moving into a penthouse inside gotham
city and that was designed more for him
to be closer to the ground to be more
more direct
the the issue with this is that in the
aftermath of that he ended up deciding
that being so close to the city was not
the best idea because it was too easy
for people to pick up and distinguish
the fact that bruce wayne was batman
right they were seeing him every day
people could find a way to break in
different things like that and putting
the pieces together was seemingly just
too easy so it didn't last all that long
and i would say
if this does remain a mainstay for james
tenion's run once he leaves
he'll go back to wayne manor right and
then we'll probably find some way in
which you know alfred
comes back probably using the lazarus
pits you know who really knows but
the the whole point behind this is that
he basically says like there's a
brownstone there that i own and i didn't
even realize that i owned it so i'm
certainly going to move into it i'm not
going to live across the bridge i'm
going to live inside this city that i
want to protect so again
kind of reiterating what we've seen
happen in years past when it came to
batman the funny thing about this is
that he had actually considered the idea
of selena kyle kind of renaming herself
right like creating a new identity and
her working alongside bruce wayne the
issue with this is
that with selena kyle and bruce wayne
spending time together and then catwoman
and batman hanging out together people
would have put the pieces together like
that they would have done it so quick
and they would have said bruce wayne and
celine and kyle are hanging out all the
time batman and catwoman are fighting
crime together all the time
is bruce wayne selena kyle batman and
catwoman
somebody somewhere would have figured
that out right the funny thing about
this though is that selena kyle had the
reverse idea that bruce wayne could just
run off with her now of course bruce's
response is i can't do that and that's
true right how's dc gonna publish batman
comics if bruce wayne's not batman it
doesn't work
[Laughter]
nobody wants to read a batman comic
where bruce wayne's not batman for like
10 years for a short amount of time sure
right like the whole aftermath of final
crisis you know where like dick grayson
was batman for a time and damien wayne
was robin sure that's interesting the
aftermath of batman nightfall
sure but in terms of like 2030 that like
bruce wayne is still not batman
people don't want that people want bruce
wayne to be batman forever right it's
just kind of the the way things are so
what comic book fans are
we do not like change and so it's one of
these things where where bruce wayne
basically and even
selena kyle basically say like we need
to to kind of get ourselves regrounded
right like we need to we need to
reground ourselves and so what's
interesting about this is
like you know selena kyle's like we'll
take one year basically one year apart
one year for them to figure things out
to get them
get things grounded to get themselves
sorted out and then at the end of that
one year
basically reconcile consolidate and see
whether or not they can move forward
together and so what you kind of end up
getting is them basically going to the
brownstone of bruce wayne and knocking
boots right i mean there's no part no no
furniture in there with selena kyle's
like who needs furniture but nonetheless
it's it's uh it's isn't it's interesting
this is a whole new batman right it's dc
taking batman back to the way he was
back during the 60s and the 70s where he
had some semblance of high-tech gadgetry
but batman comics were largely reliant
on bruce wayne's intuition right his
intelligence his detective skills
and some measure of super advanced
gadgetry but in recent years i would say
batman comics have largely focused and
shifted their focus
to like bruce wayne being able to
achieve his goals using like super high
tech stuff and i'm excited to read
comics where it's just
batman and his intellect i'm excited to
read that it's a throwback to the to the
comic to the batman comics of yesteryear
and i'm looking forward to it a lot so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like i will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you